there are different ways in which we can
understand ratios to understand weighted
averages mixtures and allegations you
need to understand ratios really well
assume there is a mixture which has two
quantities a and B the ratio of A to B
is written like this a colon B let's say
it is three to two and in the fraction
format it can be written as 3 over 2
given this ratio what will be the
proportion of a what they asked us here
is how big a is relative to the total
quantity so it will be the quantity of a
over the quantity a plus B this is the
proportion of a it will be equal to 3
over 3 plus 2 or 3 over 5 this will be
the proportion of a given this ratio and
similarly the proportion of P will be 2
over 5 in both these cases we are
comparing one quantity with the overall
quantity there is another way in which
this ratio can be interpreted what is
the percentage of a in the mixture when
we are looking at the percentage we want
to find out what percentage of the
entire quantity is a equal to so it will
just be the proportion of a in
percentage terms it will equal 3 over 5
times 100 that will be 60 percent 60
percent of the entire mixture is a what
will be the percentage of B in this
mixture then it will be 40 percent so
this ratio also tells us that 60 percent
of the mixture is a and 40 percent is B
so if the mixture has a total of 5 units
this ratio tells us that it will have 3
units of a and 2 units of B what if the
mixture has 10 units in all the total is
multiplied with 2 hence each of these
quantities is also multiplied with 2 it
will have 6 units of a and 4 units of B
and what if the mixture has 100 units it
will have 60 units of a and 40 units of
B so this ratio also tells us that the
quantity of a will be a multiple of 3 or
3x and the quantity of B will be 2x the
quantities of a and B will be multiples
of 3 and 2 respectively what kind of
questions do we encounter in the exams
we might be given a statement like 60%
of the solution is water how do we
interpret this line let's say the
solution weighs X liters this tells us
that 60% of X will be water 60 over 100
times X will be the amount of water in
the solution reducing this fraction to
its simplest form we can say that 3/5 of
the solution is water and this
indirectly tells us that 2/5 of the
solution is the rest we don't know what
the rest is
but 2/5 of the solution is something
other than water so if we have 25 liters
solution how much of it will be the
water and how much of it will be the
rest pause the video and find out water
will be 3/5 of the solution that will be
3 over 5 times 25 that would be 15
liters and the rest will be 2/5 of the
solution that will be 2 over 5 times 25
which equals 10 liters this also tells
us that the ratio of water to rest is 3
to 2 if we have 15 over 10 we get 3 over
2 if we divide 3x over 5 by 2 x over 5
we get 3 to 2 and so on so this
percentage will also give us the ratio
and what will be the proportion of water
here it will be 3 to 5 water over the
total this gives us an idea about the
solution with respect to water and what
about the proportion of the rest
the solution it will be two to five this
gives us an idea about the solution with
respect to the rest of it this rest can
be milk or gasoline or whatever it
doesn't matter what is important is how
we are able to convert from one form to
another percent to ratio ratio to
quantity quantity to percent and so on
understanding this video will help you
build a solid foundation for mixtures
and allegation problems we will cover a
few more important concepts in the next
lesson